foreign
[Music]
that debuted in the 1965 movie Gamera
the giant monster he is often stated as
a rival to touhou's Godzilla and one of
the most famous Kaiju of all time we
will showcase his Origins then his
external morphology and then lastly his
internal biology and life cycle so let's
get into it firstly his Origins there
are quite a few of them actually in the
showa era Gamora was a massive
prehistoric species of turtle that fed
on flames and other sources of heat
light and electric energy who was then
reawakened by an accidental atomic bomb
in the Arctic Ocean it is also
hypothesized that Gamera was a part of a
species of massive turtles that lived on
the lost continent of Atlantis in the
American version it is theorized that
Gamera is either a silicon or a metallic
based life form the soul multicellular
biological life form from a period of
Earth's history when creatures did not
require oxygen to live but instead
subsisted on inflammable chemical
compounds in the heisei trilogy Gamera
is a bioengineered earth Defender
created by the atlanteans to battle
Gaius and on the sea graveyard
containing numerous other Gamera bones
is discovered implying that the
atlanteans developed several other
prototypes of him before eventually
producing the last version
now his external morphology Gamera
resembles a huge heavily Armored Turtle
with a shell that serves both as a
protective barrier and a weapon his
shell is typically represented as having
sharp blade-like ridges that may be
utilized to slice and puncture his
enemies he may also use his shell to
absorb and store energy which he can
then use to fuel his attacks gamera's
head is modest in comparison to his
gigantic physique with large round eyes
to radiate a blue glow his Jaws are
strong and equipped with razor sharp
fangs allowing him to bite and tear at
his enemies his neck is shot in robots
helping him to support his large head
his skull is also armored with two
massive projecting toss emerging from
either side of his lower jaw gamara's
limbs are strong and powerful with big
clawed feet and Claude hands that can
strike a grapple he has four robust
limbs each with three digits that can
sustain his tremendous weight front
limbs are often bigger and more muscular
than his rare Limbs and the feet are
frequently lot yet still robust enough
to kick in combat with his tail is
typically shot and stubby though some
variants have longer tails with spikes
of fins gamera's tail is also powerful
and flexible capable of serving as a
whip-like weapon as well as providing
balance and support his shell and limbs
are his main melee weapons for attack
and defense
now let's take a look at his internal
biology he is a being of Flesh and organ
systems but of a unique nature to other
life forms he is said to have an oil bag
which can store and allow it to drink
oil and other flammable liquids and a
cold sack that enables him to eat coal
as well as uranium and other solid fuels
these materials are then sent to the
melting furnaces which are his stomach
where they are burned and converted into
thermal energy and these organs are also
called the thermal energy conversion
intestines his thermal energy heart is
said to have extraordinary power and his
high fever muscles are known for their
ability to produce 10 000 times the
force of any human muscle and withstand
high temperatures it is this internal
mechanism that allows him to spew fire
plasma balls and variations of fire
attacks Gamera cells allow him to
regenerate quickly even when wounded
these cells of his are also heat
resistant and thermal energy resistant
there are hundreds of times larger than
normal animal cells and also very
durable with armored cell membranes thus
making his entire body sort of like a
tank on full legs his brain is highly
developed allowing him to communicate
with people using telepathy and send
Spirits additionally his body brain and
cells are evolved engineered or
developed to withstand his rapid
rotation during flight and his blood can
absorb heat Flames high voltage current
and even nuclear fuel which is then
converted into plasma energy for his use
Gamera perhaps most notably possesses
the ability to fly in general He will
draw his arms legs head and tail inside
his shell fire flame from the holes
inside his arms and leg cavities and
spin around like a frisbee he also
possesses a second mode of flight in
which he just draws his legs and
discharges Flames from the leg cavities
like a dual rocket system and flies like
a jet by adopting the style of flying
Camaro's arms will lengthen and stretch
out into Wings providing him greater
aerodynamic and control finally Gamera
Can manipulate its own genetic structure
through chromosomal manipulation
allowing him to adapt to different
environments and evolve for combat this
shows his transformational or
hyper-evolutionary ability anyway to his
weaknesses although his shell is said to
be very durable his stomach however is
softer and often not as resilient as he
has been cut and gouged in his stomach
by his enemies to the point of bleeding
gamera's internal organs are also
vulnerable to parasitic actions as shown
when he fainted and turned into a
deathly white when the baby Jagger was
growing inside his lungs his only major
weakness is gold the monster bargain was
able to hurt Gamera using his freezing
spray and at one point of time
scientists nearly defeated him using a
special cadmium freezing bomb
so going to the last part of this topic
the life cycle there was no clear
mention of gamera's life cycle in the
original Gamera movies yet in several
contemporary flicks and other media
Gamera has been shown to be a monster
having various phases of growth gamara
for example is seen to have a child
which was considerably small and called
Toto and was weaker than his adult form
several other media Outlets have also
stated that gamara can deposit eggs or
lay eggs implying that he has a
reproductive cycle and whether he is a
she therefore anyway we can summarize
that Gamera is a life form with a
metallic carbon base or bioengineered
must have a simple life cycle as in
laying eggs a fast-growing juvenile
stage and lastly his adult monster
thermal form
so that's all about Gamera so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam